well fish and chips served by our local
chippy as we call it in the in the uk is
the taste of the british summer but this
year is the chippies themselves getting
battered russia's invasion of ukraine
has sent fuel and energy prices soaring
jacking up the cost of both the fishing
and the frying parts of the cod and
haddock are up 75 in a year sunflower
oil by 60 of flower prices by 40
tick tock has saved the day for one
friar in coventry the binley mega chippy
has incredibly racked up millions of
views online after a catchy song about
the chippy went virally
[Music]
[Music]
it's sort of catchy i guess i'm joined
now by frank nakara whose family owns
the binli mega chimpy uh frank great to
talk to you um can i just ask you how
tough is it right now to be in your line
of work given these extraordinary
escalating prices
hi pierce how are you doing um it's uh
it's it's a very very difficult uh time
of um year and uh it's with all the
rising prices and the war in in ukraine
um it's very very difficult to actually
maintain
the margins and keep the staff on
without uh
having to raise prices too much but
we've managed to balance it out really
well i mean what you've done brilliantly
is you've used tik-tok to turn
yourselves into a global phenomenon
well the viral
jingle that you've just been listening
to
thank you who for having done it but
we've obviously benefited the massive
way from it um and obviously we've set
up our own accounts obviously my account
i'll put it on little tick tock reels
and some instagram
and uh to push it even further to
gain more publicity and obviously his tv
progression interviews um but yes it's
it's certainly helped and
helped
create a lot of business and for the
future as well if you could have a word
with boris johnson
the prime minister what would you most
want him to do right now for businesses
like you
uh take the v8 back to five percent that
would be a great help
yeah well good point we'll put it to him
if you have the gumption to come on the
show i'll ask him uh frank good luck to
you i love i love the jingle i love the
business you're doing i love the fact
you're defying this you know near
recession now and doing a roaring trade
and next time i'm up there i'll come and
have a nice cotton ships with you
i wish you would and if i send you a
t-shirt this is all for charity we've
got something i've designed with me and
a supplier um
we're gonna we is there's a website
where you can actually buy all our
merchandise this particular merchandise
and every single penny that we make from
that charity yeah i'll get a t-shirt to
you and a mug would you actually wear it
on your show i probably wouldn't wear it
on the show but i might do it for social
media for you just to try and capitalize
on your tick-tock fame frank good to
talk to you get back get back to work
thanks
thank you all experience take care yeah
all the best to you well john and esther
a bit of
fun oh hang on there's somebody at the
door
oh my gosh i've already had a bite today
now don't worry though you've already
had one fishing stick today how often do
you get stuck into two of them these are
very good they're local are they healing
right okay i have a tip please tears
just quickly your reaction i mean honest
tip no get out of it
your tip is that you get to work with me
every day the
let me just ask you on a serious point
the amount these guys are having to pay
extra just in the last six months alone
because of inflation ukraine all these
things and post pandemic really tough
out there what did you think of his idea
of reducing bat
well i can understand why
it would help him but of course we have
already an enormous debt burden which we
accumulated during kovid and to ask the
chancellor to find a measure which would
cost an awful lot of money i think it's
better to target the help on those who
really need it but i do want to say one
thing about what frank was saying
because frank is struggling but there is
behind the problems frank facing is
facing what i fear is going to become a
global crisis
because if you look at those parts of
the world that depend on ukraine for
their grain supplies for their oil
supplies potentially we are looking at a
humanitarian i completely agree i think
this is going completely unnoticed by
large swathes of people
is the the
what's going on in ukraine the
stranglehold they have on things like
flour oil
could be devastating in many parts of
the world yes let's do it hey criticism
no i know i know you're a fitness
fanatic i know i hope i can put back
your regime um just by a few weeks
what do you make though of you know
you've got the fish and ship guy there
just a local business we were hearing
one of the crew actually his dad's
working fish and ship shops and three of
them have shut down in the last year and
this is devastating i mean so many um
shops on my high street have shut down
and i see it all over the place you know
and you were saying that food prices are
increasing all over the world i believe
wheat prices um in egypt have gone about
250 percent can you imagine they're the
largest consumers of wheat in the world
and overnight the price they're paying
has gone up 250. the longer the wall
goes on the worse this is going to get
almost 25 million tons of grain sitting
in the port of odessa and they can't get
it out and
putin knows all this yeah right so part
of his part of his strategy is to put a
stranglehold on energy and resources and
food because he knows eventually we may
have to wilt but we have to break the
gridlock right because we can't just
keep funneling money to this war that we
don't see an end in sight i think that's
a bigger problem as well because these
problems are just going to keep getting
worse and worse you know what there's a
lot of bad stuff going on there have
your fish and chips
and let's just try and enjoy at least
that